now
we are about to have our
uh next speaker uh who you've already
met today
but once again i will introduce him he
is
kai whiting he is the researcher and
lecturer in sustainability and stoicism
based at the uc levane belgium
he is the co-author of the book being
better stoicism for a world worth living
and tweets at
kai whiting and blogs over at
stoitkai.com and
if he ever decides to say that he wants
to pick you up the airport be
expected that he'll take you via public
transportation
this is kai whiting's talk on stoicism
for a world worth
living hello and thank you for being
here with me today
my name is kyle whiting and i'm based at
the uc le van
in belgium i'm really grateful that we
could spend the time some time together
here
a stokornx midwest 2020
some of you may know my work already
but for those of you that don't know it
um i'm particularly
associated with stoicism and
sustainability
so before i launch into statism for a
world worth living in
i just want you to think about the blank
space that i've left on purpose here
i want to ask you to fill that space
with the world that you
think would be the world worth living in
now that's you to do that because
steroids doesn't have any rules so to
speak
the only one is that virtue is good and
the only good
and the only thing that's sufficient and
necessary for us to prosper as humans
what is the world what does a world
worth living in mean to you
would he look the same would he look
different
and what would be your role in it
so most people that have come across me
and came across me
in stockholm london 2018
when i started to ask what is tourism
for a better world
what does it mean is this philosophy
just a personal one or is there
something more it can offer
and in my storycon speech i
showed an image and the image was in
addition to heuricles circles of concern
with the concept
really highlighting to us what our
obligations
and civic duties are to ourselves our
family
friends and wider humanity but i argued
that there was a massive thing missing
there was an elephant in the room and i
thought that was
uh i didn't think that by myself i had
co-authors but i was very determined
to highlight the fact that sometimes we
really do not see the wood for the trees
we do not see the obvious
and it was obvious to me at least that
without the earth
humanity could not prosper without the
natural processes that we take advantage
of
we wouldn't have the clean water in the
clean air without the result is that we
extract consume and dispose of an and
for an
unfortunate manner we wouldn't have the
social economic development
that we depend on today for much of our
ways of living and
i also reflected on the fact that
sustainable development
as in making sure that present
generations do not consume so much that
future generations have nothing left
is inherently linked to the four strike
purchase
of course if we're greedy which is the
opposite of tough control we will
consume too much
if we do not think it's reasonable that
future generations have a chance to
live according to their own uh nature
and meet their own needs
i think that's a question of justice
i think it's kind of it takes courage to
say that sometimes when
we have me myself and i mantra
when we talk about i want it now i think
it's a question of wisdom too
about giving our children what they need
i think that's a wise thing to do or why
bring them in
into the world in the first place
and i left people with harare's quote
why not add humankind and planet earth
to the list of
loyalty of looking at one's neighborhood
and i think that's a very cosmopolitan
idea
and i felt that taking into
consideration
the earth and behaving in a way that
enhanced the way that nature
operates and functions is living
according to nature
and that certain practices such as how
we
farm do not allow wildlife to live
according to their
nature and therefore i didn't find it
very coherent with the stoic
message of liver according to nature
which is both our own nature and
nature as the whole
my research extended from that point
into other things i was particularly
interested in what it meant to be human
so along with uh greg settler professor
chris gill and the united
weren't the st reasonable did they
create did they possess
reason were they rational and
what did that mean i asked myself the
question various on various occasions
what can strike stoichiology do
is it just some interesting idea that
has no value today
or as i i see it can it not
allow us to approach environmental
challenges in a different way
does logocentric mean reason uh
centered pantheism tell us something
that we're missing
are we missing the wider picture by
assuming
that the atheistic or agnostic
interpretation of terrorism
may be the only way or the most
appropriate way
that i'll leave that for you to decide
because that's something that i
often work on think about i also worked
with william stevens on how a historic
might approach dietary matters
if they were really sincere in their
commitment to live according to nature
if anybody wants a copy of my research
papers you can find them
on strikekai.com or you can fill in the
contact form on stoicky.com
and ask me for them and i'm happily
sending them to you
for me the question has always been and
will always be
about the common good i see
stories as something that is not just
restricted to
a quote unquote self-development it's
not just restricted to the individual
for me it has collected value because
to live according to nature isn't just
about you
virtue does not exist in a vacuum it
cannot
exist in stoicism in a vacuum because it
must be made
manifest for our actions and although we
can act
by ourselves and we often do we don't
always or necessarily restrict
our virtuous actions to the things that
only linked
us how could we if we are employers
or employees if we are teachers or we're
students
if we go and talk to
anybody how do we talk to them why do we
talk to them
that's not a restricted isolated affair
there is a collective
situation that we do have to consider i
think
strikes are definitely called to engage
in what some people might call
a self-development approach i do believe
that we are called to look at our
strengths and work out how they can be
used in the most appropriate manner
but i do believe that an appropriate
manner is not restricted to
how can i have a bigger bicep how can i
have a flat
stomach how can i be the most educated
individual that worked
walked up on the earth and had the phd
piece of paper behind me
how can i earn more money how can i in
enhance my social status i just don't
believe
for one moment that stoicism is talking
about
those kind of things when we are asking
about what is your individual nature
what is your role what is your strengths
what are your talents and abilities
stereoism
really talked about applying those
things
so that we can help society so that we
can play our role
or playing a role is really
a one man or one with band theater piece
it really is looking at am i behaving in
a way
which is compatible with the common good
to use mark as a religious expression
what is good for the beehive
is good for to be
so you know definitely in my opinion had
the good of the whole in mind when he
founded and developed historicism as a
philosophy
this is obvious to me because he spent a
lot of time
writing his greatest masterpiece
which was the republic the republic was
not a self-help book about how to be a
better individual
for your own sake it was about how to
fulfill your civic duties how to be a
better citizen because the republic
was the ideal stoic city of
sages of the wise virtue
was the only distinguishing feature
and despite the fact that a lot of
people come across terrorism
through silicon valley's tourism a
phrase that leonidas constantin across
and i coined to highlight the
superficial
understanding of soils and when it's
only restricted
to enhancing business acumen that's
terrorism is a lot it's just done a lot
of people come to
and through and yet zeno says
that the ideal city has no money
that the wise would only need to trade
they'd have no need for money
so if he does not agree that there's a
need for money
i really don't think he would agree with
historicism that is is
focused on how to improve
your strengths in business and how to
make
more money or how to promote yourself or
get promoted
doesn't mean that those things are not
um
significant on occasion for some people
but it's certainly not a stoic
virtue it's not what job you have but
how you go about doing a new job in line
with the state of virtues and in line
with learning according to nature
seeing those republic has no temples has
no sacred buildings
reverence to god or to reason is very
much
an outdoor activity so i really see that
living point in nature isn't just about
me myself and i or humans as individuals
it really is
aligning oneself with the divine reason
men and women wear the same clothes
why because
the clothes are not a defining factor in
one virtue they make no difference
for the same reason xeno neither
condemns
homosexuality or polyamory why
because again he did not believe that
homosexuality or paranormal polyamory
per se
affected or influenced upon one virtue
everyone in zeno republic lives
according to nature
there's only natural law there's no
universal law that you must do something
other than
progress towards virtue they can't be
because he recognizes that everybody has
a different role
um you might say does that mean there's
no traffic lights then there's no
traffic
wardens there's nothing no parking
tickets well
a sage if he had a you know it was
parking somewhere he'd have a very good
reason it wouldn't just be because
he wanted to quickly nip or she went to
quickly nip to the shop
and get something and couldn't be
bothered to walk the extra five minutes
it would be because there was literally
an emergency
and it was reasonable that they'd park
this there'd be no reason to have
even pocket tickets
seeing those ideas i would argue
aren't typical to self-help self-help
isn't typically focused on civic duties
or the collective or what it means to be
part of the whole
it certainly doesn't normally celebrate
virtue
as the main focus as in being having
money
is a preferred preferred indifference
like if i
have it then good i'd rather have it
than not have it but not the cost of
virtue
so i started to wonder with leonardo's
constant course if it was possible to
write
a book based on zeno's principles or his
principles and those are developed by
his students not a book about
xena but a book about how his principles
worked and how you could apply them
in the contemporary context so to do
that we did take
zeno but we also took chrysippus who's
uh he was a long-distance runner
and cliamies who was a boxer and
theorist who is my
favorite stoic often overlooked he was
the stoic responsible
for taking steroids of them to sparta
the connection between stoicism and
sparta is not resilient and
toughness it is political reform because
spherus helped king clearman is the
third
bring social economic and land reform to
sparta
so when people tell me stories deserve
is only for the individual
that when i start to use collective
applications i'd simply
say you didn't look at the primaries
that i looked at perhaps
you didn't do your homework perhaps
we also um so yeah if you want to know
more about spherus and sparta we did
spend a long time writing about it
because it really is overlooked
a lot of times spherus has only really
talked about me
and he says i don't think that really
was a pomegranate
uh those that who have been starting
them a long time now
you're you'll probably know that story
but you may not know that macaveli
speaks about king clearman is the third
and historic
reforms so that was the point of of
being better it was to express
you know the stories or elaborate upon
the sort of xeno
spheres christians glianthis
even pacidonias pernitius caso
we wanted to do it in a way that was
accessible to people if they just
picked up the book because they like the
cover which i actually like too
so it would be a reasonable thing to do
and people who had been into stories of
them for years i actually did
a few questionnaires with people a few
surveys with people to see what they
knew and what they didn't know
what they'd focused on in their own
research even academic studies i was
able to see okay what who do they really
focus on and
who maybe not so much because i wanted
people to know
about maybe some of the quote unquote
they're systemic not because they're not
as virtuous but because they didn't
write as much of their writings were
lost
so if you so i wanted to we've allowed
to do that i wanted to show that stories
and
citizen was something bigger than we had
imagined when we talk about self-help
i also wanted to show there were
contemporary examples where you could
use those principles and i will talk
about
how we do that in terms of living
according to nature
now before i do that though i think it's
very important to say
in order to reiterate that your role
is yours there's no universal rule
because
each rule would be slightly different
according to what your role was
so in the book although we give examples
we don't tell you what you should or
shouldn't do
because that really depends on who you
are
it depends on where you are it depends
on what family you belong to what friend
you have how much influence in your
friendship
circles you have what job you want based
on your preferences
the worst thing you can do actually is
to
occupy a role that isn't yours
advertiser says if you take on some role
that is beyond your powers you disgrace
yourself
why because you neglect the role that
you were capable of fulfilling
so we we didn't want everybody to
suddenly run out and say this is what
still
this is how i i act living according to
nature i should be
x y and z no that really isn't how
steroidism works that's the beauty and
the difficulty the challenge
and the i think the the benefit of
things of being static or deering to
strike principles is that
you do have that flexibility and you are
called to use your reason which you
possess
through um the divinity of or the logos
or the patterning of the universe
depending how you want to see it
so the most important thing i can offer
you today is i'm not going to tell you
how to live according to nature
in a b or c i would say that you should
examine your life and spend
time working out what you who you are
what you can reasonably be
and do based on the various factors that
make you who you
are i mean certainly just to give you an
example we don't have empathy
why because i can't put my shoes myself
in your shoes
if i did that my feet would be scrunched
right
they might be too big or too small and i
don't you don't need to know how my
feet fit in your shoes you need to know
how your feet fit in your shoes
that's why again we don't really say as
a strike you should do this
and why i highlighted it in stockholm
2018 that
i think it is strikes to be sustainable
because i believe that that is a modern
manifestation
of the virtues but how you do that that
depends on your role
how do you undertake your role so i've
just told you that
once you've found you know that no one
has exactly the same
as everybody anybody else because of the
different circumstances
but i can tell you that it is clear how
we undertake it regardless of what that
role is
and hepatitis gives us this information
if someone ordered a singer in a chorus
to know himself would he not attend to
the order
paying attention both to his fellow
chorus members and deharmonizing with
them
and i think that's absolutely right i
actually like to think of roles
um in terms of either being an orchestra
or being in a choir so depending on what
position you play in the orchestra in
what instrument you play but also
where you are are you number one being
in this are you number two would it take
the exact
time that you play or the exact solo
that you do
it's not it's not good enough in an
orchestra to be the best finalist
think in terms of you can play the
violin slower or faster than
uh as need be your fingers are stronger
you hold the
hold the bow better it's not about that
being
number one viennaist also is about
playing your violin
to enhance the collective sound
you can imagine if the violin starts to
play the most beautiful piece at the
wrong time
and they'd cease to be the the number
one or the top feminist
it is about making those around you
sound
good too it's about harmonizing the same
in your voice you
you cannot drown out other people's
voices and you must be careful with your
tone
and with the heaviness of the note and
this just shows you that
we are all called to work towards the
common good rather than causing
friction as individuals and you can
apply that on the wider
scale i think that it's about what am i
doing for nature am i working with
nature i'm against it
traditionally stories has talked about
the animal the universe
a living breathing thing and we're just
part of a limb so we can choose to
go with the animal or we can choose to
go against it
when we choose to go against the animal
we suffer and the animal itself would
suffer because it doesn't function
in the way they should and nor do we
the important thing here as well is to
be consistent
if you do one thing right
one time that doesn't mean that you're
creating character
that doesn't mean that you're acting in
accordance with your rock that's why i
think we have the phrase
he's acting out she's acting out of
character
character is built in succession you do
acts over and over and over again and
then people say you're generous it's not
because you're generating one time
that you suddenly become known as a
generous person for example
and we have many wrongs for our life
just because you have one role now
doesn't mean that you're going to have
the role for your
rest your life for example if your
parents die you cease to
be their son right if you move
if you change jobs you cease to be a
police officer you may now be working in
i.t
and what you do in that role cannot be
the same because it wouldn't make any
sense
in terms of contradictory a very clear
example would be a judge
if if they're not just they're actually
contradicting what is expected of them
what could be reasonably expected of
them
and so when we try to play a role that
isn't out every time says we
contradict our capacity for reason and
we talked about brutalized humanity
being
where our sense of shame i mostly have
been chopped off
because we're not doing things right for
the right reason
so once you know your role once you've
thought about it
how would you live it personally i'd
like to give pacidonius
example which is one example but we do
give in the book which is linked which
we give in terms of living according to
nature
and i like this example because being an
academic it really does relate to
me so i'm nowhere near as scientific or
academic as he was i really think that
he was the greatest academic that we've
had
in the history of studies he was
certainly revered by seneca galen stravo
for his breadth from depth of knowledge
he knew from anthropology literally to
zoology
and he really believed that science or
what we
would now call science was the way to
understand the mind of god and you might
even say move you know
move over stephen hawking he was the
first scientist who really wanted a
grand fear of everything
he thought the more he knew the more he
would he would understand god the more
he would be
intricately connected to the mind of god
and he would be
um as a result living in a more virtuous
manner
uh if anybody wants to know where this
picture is is actually the
archaeological museum in naples so
you know this man is uh recognized
and revered even though he's not
necessarily seen as
a significant stroke when people talk
about say
marcus aurelius but he is he was
recognized he was
revered for his knowledge
he's believing god um drove him
high and wide and we have to remember
that in the ancient period it wasn't
just getting on a plane and sitting
there for a couple of hours however
uncomfortable that might be
to get from one place to the other it
could be a very dangerous affair
i often say that exile people think the
problem is being
excelled uh back in the action period
that you're in a period in a place you
don't want to be i would say the danger
is
the process of going to where you are
being exiled because
you'd go from no man's you know from
city to a no man's land it would be a
dangerous place you might run out of
food you might get sick
you might not have you might lose your
way and you're very likely to be robbed
or
subjected to a violent crime so he
really moved a lot for somebody
back in that period because it was
knowledge that drove him he was not
content to sit in his
uh his office or he's in the equipment
office or a lab
he had to go out and see things he he
went to see druids to understand the
tides and celestial bodies
he could have just took you know
somebody else's account julius caesar
for her own account but he wanted to
know
himself what madrids were like
interesting enough wasn't only about
knowledge i mean he was really like the
the brainy stoic of the day but he
had a fundamentally important uh
consideration and that was to in his
role
as a scientist was to teach and not just
to teach facts but to teach values
and cicero was one of his students and
he calls him the greatest of all stokes
and i really don't believe that cicero
would just call him that because he was
knowledgeable
we all know someone who's knowledgeable
who doesn't want to share their
knowledge and actually we can build
resentment
sometimes it was because he was
knowledgeable and he wanted to share it
he wanted other people to draw closer to
god too
he wanted them to do that so they could
fulfill their obligations to civic
duties not just because they could be a
better person
in for their own sake because why
going back to our duties as stoics is to
be pro-social
we need to keep the ball up in the enemy
in the air we can't be like these two
individuals fighting over the ball
trying to keep it for ourselves
we are called to always work in a team
and with each other
so give you an example pacidonius told
pompey
uh the roman statesman another one of
his students try to
reason with the pirates and
be humane with them do not punish them
harshly which is a very unpopular piece
of advice
upon p and respect for sidonius and one
who because he wanted to understand
the humanity of those parts and he
wanted to really act in a way that was
in accordance with divine reason he
actually agreed that pepsidonius's
approach was better and spared their
lives
in the book we go from passengers to a
modern application i actually really
like this application
because it involves a community so a lot
of times in in self-help books
you might get a very famous individual
who does something
extraordinary and yes we do have some
examples of people who do things
extraordinarily and rightly their
example is given in the book to
encourage us to move forward to push our
own boundaries
but i also with leo wanted to make sure
that we gave some sort of community
sense so
one thing examples we gave was cambridge
central mosque
which is europe's first eco mosque
so this community if you're a muslim you
may already know
it's cool to play five times a day the
men are obliged if they're if they're
close enough to the mosque to go
and women are actively encouraged and
these prayers
are in line with what's going on with
the sun during the day
so you can see that the prayer the most
most sacred moment of
a muslim's life is intricately connected
the position of the sun in the sky
it's a it's a building that's used on a
daily basis
and it really is as i said rooted in
even seasons so winter times will be
prayer time will be different
summer times and that's why ramadan as
well get shorter and longer
so the cambridge uh community felt that
if they
built a master that was both pleasant to
the eye and pleasant to
being whilst also being ecologically
considerate
would be the way forward to revere god
and appreciate
his creation they saw it as their role
as muslims to build the most sacred
building in their lives
in a way that was i would say living
according to nature and that was a
decisive action that makes sense
according to who they are
so this outside is a picture of outside
the mosque and
you can see again the sense of the
garden the sense of being outside and
being at one with god
the building itself each soul the prayer
room it's about the breath of the define
there's natural light and ventilation
there's heat pumps there's
efficient energy uh light bulbs heating
and cooling
is as needed and it's completely natural
works with nature rather than against it
you have rainwater collection green
roofs and bird boxes
and importantly from a cosmopolitan
point of view so the idea of the
universal humanity it actually has
features that wouldn't be out of place
in a rural churchyard in england
because they wanted to integrate and
incorporate
values to demonstrate they saw their
identity as muslims but equally
acknowledge their identity as part of
the english
community which doesn't always happen in
uh in mosque building
exercises because it can have quite an
oriental look
the result was that people felt more
comfortable in visiting the mosque even
non-muslims like to visit they have uh
various tours which is why i
recommend thoroughly going just so that
you can see for yourself the beauty of
this building
and they were upset that there was a bus
stop in
in front of in front of the um building
because it really
disrupted their views that was like a
different way of looking at like we as
muslims we are called to do something
that's unusual
in the traditional english context but
how can we do it in a way that brings in
an invite
rather than creates a sense of otherness
um returning back to you
now so you've just
been told well i've just told you
there's no one-size-fits-all
they're living according to nature will
always depend on who you are your
preferences and your circumstances
and there will be it will be a factual
of those those various
variables however there are a few
pointers in the sense that stoics are
expected to be knowledgeable about the
world we are expected to know something
or know
someone who knows something we're not
called to know everything
the sage uh the the most uh
the wisest human that could ever live
and face a human existence
um is as rare as a phoenix and yet they
are not
all knowing but they wouldn't and when
they don't know though
they know who it would be appropriate to
ask
we also we must not just take um
political parties or certain newspapers
or a certain friend's opinion unless we
weigh that up and say is it likely that
they
really do know about this that would be
a wise thing to do
and to give you a slightly easier
example like okay i i do know something
about what does that mean i i should do
well if you're an architect you know how
to build united designer building
so i would argue if you're a sage
architect you would design it in a way
that works in accordance with nature
that doesn't go against
natural cycles it doesn't demand extra
energy
if you just live there you're not an
architect and i would say the way you
live
uh reflects your desire to live
according to nature
um the way you arrange things the way
the
the way you buy things and where you buy
things and the energy you use and how
you use it and why you use it that way
that would be living according to nature
not it's not about calling you to be the
architect and the builder and building
this
beautifully ecologically friendly
environmentally friendly house
is about doing what you must do in your
role
to consider it properly and to do it
well
so i hope that this presentation has
given you some
some indications as to how you might
how you might well consider
living in accordance with nature
according to your role how you might
think about coming
to your role again
i'm very approachable you can email me
via strikekai.com you can ask me for
the papers you can tweet me i'm very
open
on the facebook groups various of them
so if
if you have further questions about
living according to nature or even about
the book being better i'm happy to
answer it
um thank you very much for joining me
and i hope that you find it interesting
and you feel encouraged in being able to
think carefully about your role and to
live
in accordance with the beautiful world
that we have thank you
thank you very much for that video
you're very welcome thank you for
inviting me it was a privilege it was
always so confused to be able to share
ideas
um well i guess uh could you tell us
a little bit about your book and when
it's expected to come out
yeah so it's coming out in april and it
was like i want to buy it now i was like
yeah i'd like it to be out now we're all
practicing temperance right
so it's good to practice that and there
is actually a bonus of not
being out right now in the sense that i
think it's good to
reflect on something like okay what does
those mean to me
and not just go out and buy something
just because you like
like a talk i mean and obviously that's
like an
ideal situation in the in the
capitalistic or near liberalism
kind of setting but i think if an idea
is strong enough
people remember it so when it's out it's
out so i'm
trying to purchase patients too so the
book is actually written
i can't say much and too much the book
is actually written so it's literally
the copy editing stage
like the ideas are there the idea is not
going to change
i guess they're trying to delete my
british british english
because it was really strange to write
it for a
predominantly american audience so that
was like what do you mean you don't want
me to put you in color that was really
painful
but uh so that's i think they're trying
to do that because um
basically british people didn't
understand american expressions but
not the other way around so i think that
they're trying to make it a little bit
um
more general in terms of language that's
where we're at
and also from a copyrighted point of
view some of the strike terms are quite
complicated so they have to make sure
like
this is clearly explained somebody could
go to the bookstore
to use an american phrase or bookshop to
use a british one and get
and understand what indifferent means so
you know it is there it is written
but we're just ironing out like
differences in
cultural differences that i didn't know
existed to put it like that
watch your mic there um so we had a
question here from steve
um as we wait with patients for your
upcoming book where can we learn more
about
separas serious it's actually stevie's
i mean it's really hard to get the life
of plutarch
is uh sorry yeah plea talks about the
life of arges iv
sorry bluetooth is a really good
reference for that but you really have
to dick
so most uh in modern strike movement we
tend to
concentrate on the pomegranate but and i
also had to go through like machiavelli
as well
so you have to kind of like put the
jigsaw pieces together
so like i mean somebody asked me
recently what would be the difference
between like your book and the one that
just came out with ryan holiday
and i would say well different audience
different kind of style
uh he probably didn't dig as deep as an
academic
might doesn't mean he didn't but i i
think like
geek 12 years training to be an academic
gives you like the ability to go right i
need this piece
and cross-reference in a way that maybe
others haven't been trying to do that
so spheres was quite tough to get
penitus he's
like he's really important in the period
that he's in
but again you have to go through the
pieces there was a lot of work in
cross-referencing with colleagues so for
example out of nucci and go okay the
greek word is these
things like that so it was really an
in-depth thing uh
i think the easiest easiest way is
unfortunately to wait for the book and
then we can talk about more because i
wasn't going to send you loads of
fragments
so i try to put it together then oh yeah
sony plutarch's life of arches the
fourth if you're really into it
which i know you are steve uh so
uh greg seyler has what mistaken
interpretations of classical stoic ideas
would you say most get in the way
of a productive modern stoic approach in
the present
i think the biggest misunderstanding and
you and i have spoken about this
on video is that people have a very sort
of it's about um
me myself and i like this most
superficial so i'm not talking just to
clarify everybody else i'm not talking
about
academics necessarily or people being in
studios in quite a while
the first thing is always about often
always about what weight sterzin does
for me
and as i said in the speech like that's
a really silly question
i feel like jfk right but it is a little
bit about what can you do for your
cosmopolitan
community right rather than what can you
do for your country but i think jfk
although is a very american
kind of speech is actually very in a
sense
it kind of play if you play it why that
would actually be a very stoic sentiment
so i think unfortunately there is a sort
of selfish
element that gets in the way that people
say okay i can't why would i care about
the environment i don't control it
well you know i i'm not responsible for
all the plastic in the sea
and i always say to them what happens if
that one turtle that is
going in the sea swimming around snorts
the straw that you drank
that drank from you don't know if that's
your straw and if you hadn't done that
maybe that's how i wouldn't have died so
it's like okay you've got this massive
problem
but if you said okay everybody's going
to die one day let's get rid of all the
doctors
people would say that was silly people
would say i was criminal if i did that
yeah when i talk about environmental
issues people are like no it's just just
too much
but if i talk about like medical issues
like okay so your mom's gonna die one
day why don't we just leave her to die
like everyone was like oh my gosh so
it's kind of like this
this this disconnects with if it's a
medical issue we understand that we
really care about our
you know our parents or our kids if it's
an environmental issue
there's not this real understanding or
literacy or eco-literacy about
we should really care about the planet
too thanks greg for that question
um uh mark asks us uh was the slide
about pasadonius going to see the druids
himself a recommendation to experience
things or ideas
firsthand and not rely on others
interpretations or writings thereof
i mean absolutely he could have just
like for whatever because julius caesar
wrote a lot of propaganda people say
i mean that wasn't there so i'm not
going to say but there is this sort of
notion that
it was a very roman take i mean the same
as poneitis is very
right he we speak about politics
specifically he's uh
pasadena's mentor about how he takes
certain ideas
he's not a kim kardashian of the day but
there is a similarity to being having a
very powerful family and obviously the
kind of certainism that he wanted
he changed the flavor so this is really
important though when you when you
when you go to anything so yes at the
moment probably not traveling is the
best idea so it doesn't mean you have to
physically travel
it's more like being willing to go to
the primary sources
now or go to someone that knows a lot of
time we spend on social media and i
include myself
and i've had to learn to withdraw like
do i know about this subject do i
actually know something about it
the answer is like am i willing to find
out the answer may
maybe yes and for example um mark i've
asked greg sadler a lot of times
something i don't know i mean he he gets
phoned he probably has a lot of missed
calls from me but leg is just like i
don't know the answer
i'm not i'm not trained in philosophy in
the extent that he is i have
you know training in stretches and i've
prepared sort of put myself through
but i might have a question like and how
does that work with like plato's
republic
and i wouldn't know that right it's only
because i go to the people that i
consider to be an authority
uh for example steve for example i asked
him about biology
so it's about going to people it's not
like you have to go and get every single
answer
but i would say surround yourself with
people that do know things so in my case
you might say well kind of like
environmental issues
but i wouldn't be very comfortable for
example to answer about
um more psychological uh
practices that you could use in stories
and some people what would you do
to you know feel less say less
uh down or depressed and i said i don't
really know because
i don't have the answer that's not my
subject i'm giving you a piece of advice
which is one
i'm not a doctor two i'm not trained for
a psychologist in any way and three you
could probably ask your neighbor and get
just as good answer
so i think also it's about being careful
about what you know what you don't know
especially if you're in
you know you're academic or you have a
public some public authority in the
field i think it can be very dangerous
uh to overstep the mark and say yes i
know something about
cbt when in my case i know less than
most people seeing here it's just not my
subject i think that's what we're gonna
be careful about knowing and knowing
when
we should ask which is why i said the
sage doesn't know how to know everything
doesn't know everything but knows who to
ask
so a question for myself i was watching
your video and thinking about
um the the ceo's republic and do you
feel that
um that at least the traditional
stoicism is put forward
is at all compatible with capitalism
i think i think it's com i do think it
is a very good question a very lonely
question
i do we do talk about this in um in the
chapter about politics because he's so
wealthy right
he's in like this like special circle or
special friends almost
i would say capitalism yes i would say
neoliberalism no
and there is a difference i don't mind
who's responsible for the way goods are
distributed
i'm i get upset with neoliberalism
masquerade to free trade
right masquerade as capitalism so that's
what
like adam smith says like the invisible
hand but if you read his work properly
it's very clear that he says there are
checks and balances
right so yes the market looks after
itself in theory
right but there are always checks and
balances and that usually he actually
talks about like
the wealth of a nation which is talking
about within the boundaries of a nation
so this
concept of uh free trade across borders
when you have very unbalanced
let's put it this way mexico you give
mexico gives all the avocados to the ufc
you give us gives them corn syrup
that's not the imagination that adam
smith's had when he talks about the
importance of capitalism so i don't have
an issue
with capitalism per se i think it could
work i also think
if socialism has checks and balances it
can work the problem is we don't do well
with
checks and balances and that's what
stories might think is about
so if you said to me would stoics just
trade i think globally that wouldn't
make sense anymore
it doesn't make sense to do that i mean
he's talking in an eye
so you know we're going to idle city
state but if you're talking about a
global world i mean you have to be
realistic and go
but i just can't grow quinoa in london
and if i want quinoa
i'm going to have to get from bolivia or
at least from portugal because the
weather's just not going to give it give
it to me
so we've got to be realistic i don't
think it'd be i don't think that we
would be
anti-capitalism but i don't think we'd
be absolutely not near a liberalistic at
all we'd say
hang on what does free trade mean and is
the agreement
fair so i i know it's a bit of a nurse
question
but yes we do actually address that a
little bit more in the book
because of this because they're not only
being silicon valley but this kind of
thing that
they therefore if you agree with zeno
you must be i don't know communist well
no because it depends what you mean by
communist right gregory is a better
person to ask than i
am about these so uh again from greg
sadler uh you mentioned the article that
you brought
uh your co-writer leo about chris gill
and myself greg
on i think it's excellent to do
co-writing why do you think there's so
little of that
in the humanities should there be more
that's an excellent question in
humanities you don't get credit
if you co-author there's no credit for
you there's no benefit your
your pay packet is not you know your
your whole privilege as an academic is
just really not recognized
because i my pay is actually linked to
engineering and my main job is
environmental sciences and engineering
sustainability i do the stroke stuff in
my quote-unquote
spare time so i don't feel shackled
to the need to be i'm the one who did it
myself i also think like it's anti-stoic
and quite foolish actually to say well i
know everything i remember
um chris giving you fruits and leo all
of you contributing to the philosophical
things because i was really stuck
as i was able to understand the
scientific nature of what is the dna
saying
so i think the problem is that hume the
way that
the iron like ivory tower is built
it's just not it's not conducive to
actually intelligent discussion and
debate i also find in philosophy papers
nobody reference each other because
they can't say that somebody else had a
good idea whereas in engineering you
have a much more collaborative
field simply because you couldn't do a
paper it's not just that white one's
going through the calculations one's got
to do the diagrams one's got to do
the translation of the of the the
numbers into the
into english or whatever language you're
writing you just can't really do it all
yourself in philosophy because it's it's
one skill set it doesn't mean that
because
philosophers are more intelligent it's
like because it the one skills it is the
thinking and writing
one person can in theory do that because
it's much narrower when you have applied
engineering you really have to come in
together in a group
i just don't think you would be able to
write a paper by yourself i mean some
people do but it's incredibly rare
and you get credit for that the incident
there's a
great incentive to contribute and
collaborate together you get actually
for example i got praised for writing an
engineering paper with a with an
institute in austria oh my gosh they're
amazing you've got them on your site
when i do a philosophy was like what you
needed right by yourself it's a it's a
strange culture going on
thanks for your question like to expand
upon this this process
of like especially when you the book
that you're writing now
requires is greg puts it philosophical
detective work where you have to be
pouring through
potentially thousands of sources to find
your information
you find that that is actually much more
beneficial to have that
collaborator well without leia the book
wouldn't have happened
i mean i remember they said to me
my agent said you want to co-author
it was like it was that he's like i love
it but it's so unusual i call
for as well but i mean unfortunately he
died during the congress i've got a new
agent but that's what he
he just said like i i can't believe you
want to do that i'm like if i don't do
this
it's not going to happen it's going to
be poorer for it i am not trained in the
way that layer is trained
i don't have the patience to go for the
amount of primaries that you did
so that even like when i'm just getting
stuck by using most right right like
it's not about who did most the writing
okay it's about what it doesn't matter
about terms of percentage about what how
much you can say it's a
high book it's not a kite book it is the
idea was to
to bring forth a sterilism that i
thought
women would identify with because it was
based on what xeno said christopher said
cato actually did that people who
don't want to use slurs and for their
business opportunities really understand
it
i i want to write it for people like you
greg was like had this immense knowledge
i wanted to surprise you like maybe you
don't know this though
because i wanted it to be coming across
in a few levels i wanted
people who were immigrants i'm an
immigrant myself living in portugal
right now
seven expats we we criticize the idea of
like a british person gets
called an expat which i hate so we talk
about the fact that immigrant
and that leo is an immigrant too in the
us
and how all the you know early stage
more or less were
immigrants immigration came from ukraine
which is not so far from greece if you
cross
you know the lake in the middle so we
wanted to show
like this this whole lie about the dead
white men it really irritated me because
not true
like it's just not true so they were
saying like one of the marketing was
asking us
so you mean that you're you're
developing a new stylist and that's so
it's open to everyone i'm like
no like i'm not doing anything
i'm taking the ideas that are already
there which took some time because it
took a lot of it going through
machiavelli wasn't really my strong
point
it's not something i really really liked
but we got it there like
it's in plain it's in plain sight but no
no one looks at it because it's hard
to do that development and then they say
how are you going to make a self-help
book out of
really going into the life of plutarch
so i believe that in the life of argent
iv
and we're like because you need to do it
we need to show
that this is not a white male thing
it really is a cosmopolitan call but
people are lazy sometimes and that they
don't want to do that so i wanted to say
look i've done it for you
not for every story but i've done quite
a lot and we on purpose we didn't
include sunday for example we did on
purpose before that we pissed him off
people if we because we knew that seneca
would be like i should definitely be in
that kind of world before what happens
if we don't include you
just just out of principle just just for
fun like to prove that it's not all
about senegal it's not what we're all
about marcus readers
it's about this whole sort of
um story and we i know we break it down
to early middle and late story but
actually we don't tend to look at the
links between them
they kind of get lost in the translation
and i wanted to show people there's not
really if you think about it early
middle and late because there are links
between all of them so we spend a lot of
time talking about the links
and how stereo system changes and sort
of
sort of fluctuates but it's not like
it's a bar i know we do that
academically because it's easier but
it's not true so just like okay there's
there is this flip
why did this split come about what was
it about henitus and rosa that why did
that happen who was he
who was his grandparent like he was
trying to tell their story
in a way that it could you could
approach it as a woman and say
wait a minute this is a spartan queen
and she's stoic that's amazing
and then somebody said wait there's an
immigrant like they're all immigrants
that's brilliant
and a wealthy person that doesn't
emperor that's excellent so it was
trying to show that
there was something for everybody if you
just looked a bit
harder so a lot of a lot there was a lot
there was a lot of study but i'm hoping
that
even if the most accurate i might be for
example that tony long says to me well i
didn't even know that that was the kind
of goal like
could someone like my mom pick it up and
go i didn't know that
and someone like tony longo i didn't
know that so that's what we tried to do
we didn't want to tell the same story as
i had always been taught we didn't want
to tell the spirits on the pomegranate
story because it already been said
oh thank you very much kai we got to
you